[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo de chico siempre quise tener el poder
o el superpoder de poder volar el hecho
de ir en el aire sentir el aire en la
libertad la altura ver todo desde arriba
tener la perspectiva
quién es de aquí ha querido poder volar
casi todos eso es lo que yo intenté
hacer
una mañana de enero de 2011
pocos segundos pasaron cuando fallo algo
en este avión
y se fue al suelo
estuve dos meses en cama me tuvieron que
reconstruir el pie izquierdo y recuerdo
perfectamente la primera vez que pude
volver a ponerme de pie
cosas básicas como el volver a caminar
aprender y hacer consciente cada uno de
mis pasos el talón planta punta de cada
uno de los pasos que daba fue una tarea
que me llevó mucho tiempo estuve más de
dos años en rehabilitación
en ese momento lo que yo entendí o lo
que yo aprendí era la vida cambia en un
segundo
hay muchas cosas
que fueron la última vez que las hiciste
y nunca sabes que nunca las vas a volver
a hacer
no te das cuenta de la belleza de un
momento no te das cuenta de lo apreciado
que es estar ahí vivir en la hora hasta
que es únicamente
un bello recuerdo
ese mismo año en esta misma plataforma
sale una charla de rick elías rick elías
venía en el avión que aterrizó en el río
hudson
y durante su plática dice cosas que
aprendí y que sintió mente hacia el
avión fue cayendo en mi caso el medio
tiempo que hallamos aproximadamente en
dos segundos y medio
pero dijo una frase que nunca olvidé
hasta el día de hoy y todos los días
vivo con esta frase
discutimos por cosas que no valen la
pena
con personas que sí valen la pena y en
ese momento me conecté un poco por el
accidente un poco por la situación
personal que yo tenía y dije hace todo
el sentido del mundo
en realidad porque discutimos
discutimos
por diferencia de opiniones discutimos
por diferentes puntos de vista
más adelante entendí un poco cómo
funcionaba esto de esta imagen quien
cree que ambas caras es lo mismo
y empieza que son distintas
la verdad es que todos estamos viendo lo
mismo lo único es lo estamos viendo de
distintos puntos de vista
eso es lo que pasa cuando tú discutes
cuando tú discutes con un ser querido
con tus papás con tus hijos con tus
hermanos con tu pareja
qué es lo que te está afectando del
mensaje no es lo que dijo la persona con
la que estás discutiendo
lo que te afecta es como tú lo recibes
como tú lo percibes
el accidente me dejó esas dos grandes
lecciones
que he tenido que ir trabajando en sus
distintas facetas día a día
durante el último año he tenido una
sesión de desarrollo personal todos las
semanas durante una hora para entender
quién soy yo cuál es mi personalidad
porque recibo los mensajes como los
recibo porque me afecta lo que me afecta
fui a la escuela a estudiar matemáticas
era muy bueno en los números era pésimo
en muchas otras cosas historia y todas
esas cosas que en realidad yo no me
enganchaba
pero una vez en una de estas sesiones me
preguntaron humberto cómo estás y yo muy
bien
y me hizo la pregunta más incómoda a la
que me enfrentado que es bien
y en ese momento fue es que la chamba
eso es tu chamba es que la familia es tu
familia
cómo te sientes en ese momento yo me di
cuenta de que mi habilidad para
transmitir mis sentimientos era nula
tuve que empezar a buscar
fuentes personas sesiones psicólogas
para entenderme a mí mismo
para entender como veo todo lo que yo he
vivido
ese día fue el parteaguas en mi vida
el día de hoy entiendo que el 77 por
ciento de lo que tú vives día a día es
mera interpretación
la interpretación de cómo vives ese día
depende de tu estado de ánimo hacia el
ejercicio lo que tú hayas decidido hoy
en una discusión la percepción que
tienes de tu maestro con tu pareja con
quien quieras darle 24 horas mínimo
y vas a ver que pasando esas 24 horas lo
que tú decidiste lo que tú dijiste como
tú te sentiste va a ser distinto
es únicamente interpretación la tarea o
el hecho de tener que hacer todos los
días
perspectiva de lo que estás viviendo no
es fácil pero se puede hacer
después de eso
oa partir de eso
cada vez que estés frente a una
situación adversa cada vez que estés
discutiendo con una persona cercana por
algo que debería de ser banal
dos cosas dice a ti mismo si realmente
vale la pena
discutir por eso con esa persona y lo
segundo que te tienes que decir a ti
mismo y lo dijo jim wong es
no desees que sea más fácil deberías de
desear tu ser mejor
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]